take a look at the people that are
around you and if they're not on the
side of what's good for you then walk
away I think most people's friends suck
just as a general rule read about all
the people I looked up to and you know
that was kind of like my college was
finding people that did things that I
was really amazed by and then learning
as much as I could rise and shine it's
expresso time what's up believe nation
it's evan my one word is believe and I
believe in you I believe you have an
amazing gift inside you that I want to
see exploded onto the world so let's
start your day off right together grab
your coffee and sip on today's message
befriend people who want the best for
you over to you Jordan B Peterson you're
demeaning yourself you're less than you
could be and there's real judgment in
that it's harsh you know but with
friends it's the same thing you want
friends they're not friends if they're
not these people you want friends who
when something good happens to you there
that's good for you right they're happy
about that they're not like all bitter
and resentful underground and like
saying horrible things behind your back
and telling you how they did something
that was better and trying to drag you
down it's like that's not helpful and
then when something bad happens to you
and you go to them and you say look this
terrible thing happened to me first of
all they don't try to top it with some
like horrible thing that happened to
them because they don't have the
patience to listen and second they're
not secretly gloating about the fact
that catastrophe finally befell you it's
like they're actually hurt by it and
that chapter is an injunction is like
take a look at the people that are
around you and if they're not on the
side of what's good for you then walk
away because well first of all that's
best for them to if you put up with that
all you're doing is enabling it it's
like well it's okay that you mistreat me
in a way that's harmful to me and
everyone else it's like actually no that
is not okay it's not in it's not the
least
it okay that doesn't mean you shouldn't
try to help someone when they're down
that's a whole different issue I think
most people's friends suck just as a
general rule and that doesn't mean that
they don't love you that they don't care
from you they just are so caught up in
themselves that they're not thinking
about you that when you go and you share
a win their default is to think about
themselves and their lack of wins that
when you go and share a loss or you're
really down the first thing they think
about is how lucky that they are down or
that they didn't go through long so
maybe they will go through a loss is
that they're just so stuck in their own
head that they're not thinking about you
where your real friends are gonna be the
people who know what you want who know
what you are trying to get and who will
support you and cheer you and push you
until you accomplish it and get there
when I'm watching this clip what I think
of is a guy in my mastermind group and
we've been together for over a decade
now and one of the things that I've
heard him say over the past decade is
just a little bit of self defeatism a
little bit of lack of confidence you
know because I didn't go to school or
get the great education I can't have as
much success a lot of these
self-defeating thoughts and at our most
recent meeting he came up and in in two
times two different instances said that
he was a success just didn't random
sentences that came up he said but I'm
as successful as I am because of
whatever and it's the first time that I
heard him called himself a success and
he did it two times that night and
halfway through the second time I had to
interrupt him and said man I know I want
to listen I want to get through the rest
of your point but I just want to
acknowledge you because this is the
first time that I've heard you call
yourself a success and you've done it
twice tonight already and I'm so proud
of you man and and I agree I think you
are and I'm so pumped for where you're
gonna go and I just want to take that
quick time out to recognize you and I
love this new mindset in this way of
thinking that you've got and he was a
little blown away by that and and you
know everybody else in a group sort of
acknowledging him for that as well and I
think that's what friends do I think if
you know what your friends want out of
life that I think is your responsibility
to help them get there to pull them up
when they're down and to push them when
they think they've done a lot right if
they said I've done so much look at me
great amazing but I know you can do more
and if they're really down see I'm never
gonna make
you bring them back up and I think just
by defaulting to not you could do this
as for yourself for your friends by
default and do not think about yourself
first that when your friends come to you
and have a problem or want to share a
win you're not thinking about yourself
first and you're immediately
circumstances or you're thinking about
them and how you can best support them
and I think if you could be that friend
for others that's a fantastic gift you
can give them and you want to surround
yourself with people who do that for you
because that is one of the world's
greatest gifts that they can give you as
well and so I would highly encourage you
to audit your friends to think that
people who you grew up in in elementary
or high school with you are still gonna
be great friends for you if you've grown
and evolved as a human being is probably
not the best strategy to go with and if
you don't have the people who support
you and build you up then first step is
to eliminate the ones who aren't helping
you and then second step is to actively
be out looking for those new friends to
be in a great circle of because it makes
a huge amount of difference now that's a
special bonus clips for you but before
that commitment of the day you watch
another video hopefully have an impact
on you don't leave and go on with the
rest your day like everything is the
same commit to making the change somehow
in your life or in your business and
make it public leave it down the
comments below what are you committed to
change after watching this video thank
you guys so much for watching I believe
in you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shock a vinspresso
and enjoy the bonus clips
expresso give me go
everybody's successful lays of blue for
now you laid the blueprint out uh you
know I can go down a list from comedians
to actors to entrepreneurs to self-made
moguls you look at Russell Simmons you
look at jay-z
you looking Tyler Perry you look at puff
I mean you're looking at people that
start off with a small vision and that
vision manifested in something beyond
expectation so what I did was from the
people around me my mentors Eddie Murphy
Chris Rock Pryor we're all on the wall
it was all so you surround yourself with
somewhere I surround myself with a
constant reminder of who is great
constantly I come down these steps every
day I look at Richard oh he's great I
see Eddie he was great I see Chris Rock
he was great
it's a constant reminder what am I
trying to achieve I want to be great so
that motivates me
so what separates me is my drive my
drive is other people's success one of
the best things Brian taught me there he
was he was an early mentor to me one of
the quotes that his dad gave to him as
always surround yourself with people
that will inspire you or help you grow
and that was just a great piece of
advice and then I took that very
seriously and pursued people that I
looked up to or that I admired and tried
to learn things from them since I didn't
have really you know a father figure
anything like that early on I would read
about all the people I looked up to and
you know that was kind of like my
college was finding people that did
things that I was really amazed by and
then learning as much as I could and and
then what I started doing is I started
flying all the books on Nobel Prize
winners and then in literature
specifically and then I would read what
books they recommended and then I would
read the books that they recommend and
on the back of that book it would be
what this book was influenced by and so
I started going through lots of that
stuff renewal hyperlinks the most
important is tourists what I like to
call surround yourself with with your
dream team hmm I called Josh Altman's
dream team and it consists of of a good
amount of support from people that I
trust value their opinion and who I
surround myself with I always say that
you are the average of five people that
you surround yourselves with right you
ever hear that before yeah yeah I
totally Jim Rome
just made that up right so I think it's
super super important to do that so in
real estate for example I have the best
mortgage broker who's available 24/7 for
me and we've worked our way up in the
business together I have you know
everybody from the best title guy and
escrow guy and and all that so I
surround myself with this team of of
people who I can trust and they can
guide me in the right directions of
whatever I do so that's one way
obviously in any business is just
surround yourself with some with people
who support you if you had to think of
one word that's most important to you or
that sums you Apple so it would be like
a little beacon hey believe nation if
you want to know what the most important
one word is for Tony Robbins Gary
Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey will.i.am and
Howard Schultz I have a very special
secret video for you check the
description for details